joining me now to do that Byron York see
political correspondent for the
Washington examiner and Fox News
contributor and Horace Cooper author and
legal commentator all right Byron let's
start with you who's a really good pick
right now if you had to pick one VP for
Trump who would it be uh if I picked one
I would probably pick Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she's the governor of Arkansas a
trump White House veteran uh no no other
governmental experience than that but
actually a really good choice for
president Trump
okay Horus that is interesting Sarah
Sanders obviously very young knows the
president very well we know that he
respects her uh greatly
um what are your thoughts well I
actually think jungkin would be a better
running mate if you pick up Virginia and
the survey show with him on the ticket
you're very likely to carry Virginia and
that would mean you wouldn't need to
worry about a state like Wisconsin in
terms of electoral votes you must figure
out a way to grow the support on
Election Day and that's one way to do it
all right well you have it three picks
up there we're gonna get to each one but
Byron one of horus's uh choices you saw
up on the screen was Nikki Haley who uh
was very well respected governor of
South Carolina of course uh un uh
Ambassador and they had a very good
working relationship but she comes from
a different side of the you know the
philosophy in the Republican party today
no doubt but what about her
well uh as you said she's one of my
picks too is as you said the pros are
she's very very experienced both in
domestic governing and policy and in
international Affairs so that's a big
deal the the con of course she's running
against Trump and criticizing Trump but
she hasn't been that super critical of
trump and and politicians can get over
that sort of thing and besides I think
Trump kind of likes it when someone
who's been very critical of him has to
come around and maybe Kiss the Ring and
be uh uh work for him so uh yes she is
from a different wing of the Republican
party but they're out there too and they
do vote and giving them a reason to vote
for Donald Trump against they might not
vote for otherwise is not a terrible
idea so you're saying it mollifies some
of the concerns of the establishment
types who are still very worried about
President Trump's electability I
understand that let's move on to some
cabinet picks Horus the border is so
important
obviously you need someone who really
knows what they're doing and can is
credible on Border enforcement who might
Trump choose for that
well um I suggested that perhaps Abbott
might be a great pick for Homeland
Security someone who's actually
demonstrated some leadership in this
particular area and someone who people
trust would be serious about handling
the duty and someone who's had some
leadership experience he's been a
governor elected several times in the
state of Texas
well Byron I mean governor of one of the
most important economies in the world to
DHS secretary
yes it might be an emotion yeah I mean
it seems to me like a demotion I mean he
would be fantastic I agree with Horace
no doubt about it but would that be
something he would do because for a long
time people thought he had presidential
Ambitions maybe now obviously not this
time but maybe down the road absolutely
I sort of half expected him to run this
time but he did not do that you know
another possibility for DHS Trump's
talks about he talks a lot about how
well the Border was working while he was
President well why not go back to the
last DHS secretary Ken cuccinelli and
have him come back I think a lot of what
Trump is going to want to do is actually
restore the policies that he had put in
place prior to Joe Biden becoming
president and the same people could do
it
uh Horus other cabinet secretaries that
are obviously very important would be
treasury Commerce
Secretary of State CIA director I mean I
know we're this is Friday so we're
playing these games but it is
interesting and it may be something that
again mollifies the concerns of some
Independence who maybe just say I'm not
going to vote this time or others who
think I'm not sure they like but if he
did that with the Supreme Court picks in
other words like he put out a list which
I thought was brilliant in 2016 who
would put on the court why not put out a
potential list of uh cabinet picks okay
so first thing let me say is I think
that's one of the benefits that someone
like Nikki Haley might bring both as
either Secretary of State nominee or as
a running mate because places like
Michigan places like Arizona places like
Georgia have a Suburban women vote that
you might want to reach out to broadly
speaking there would be some substantial
value to just listing some names of some
people that we could trust there were
some hiccups to put it mildly when the
first round of cabinet officers were
named during the Trump Administration I
think in the end we ended up getting a
lot of good people in but it might be a
great idea like with the Supreme Court
let's find out in advance who we're
thinking about picking and let those
people get vetted yeah and Byron I think
the first hundred days there were a lot
of wasted wasted energy in the first
hundred days of Trump's uh term we can
all say that now still you know working
on the you know the my the band the
Muslim ban all that stuff that wasn't a
Muslim ban but
um mediaite by the way is reporting that
RFK Jr is planning to announce he's
going to run as an independent and he's
going to make that announcement October
9th in Pennsylvania Byron how might this
affect the race going forward is it good
for someone like Trump bad for Biden or
could there be some other contingency
develop with that well I think the the
Democratic party had been pretty
effective in shutting down any
challenges uh to President Biden and
making sure there weren't going to be
any debates there wasn't going to be any
sort of uh even acknowledgment that
there's a contest going on in the
Democratic party and indeed Robert F
Kennedy Jr has never surged he's never
hit above 20 percent a lot of times he's
down around 14 or so he does represent
people who might be Democrats who don't
want to vote for Joe Biden it would seem
to me that if he announced an
independent run that could be very
damaging because there are those
Democrats we know they're there they
don't want Joe Biden maybe they're not
focused exactly on who they want but any
credible choice they would take
all right Horus I know I heard you cough
there now I'm worried about you you I
mean something's going around but I'm
glad I'm glad you're still there a Horus
I had a coughing fit the other night so
I'm just empathizing with you on the air
um on on the question of RFK Jr then you
got Cornell West who uh is still out
there he's driving them absolutely nuts
because he's just like look I represent
the real liberal Progressive wing of
this party you guys are kind of Half
Baked on that in in that category might
he still be a problem for this uh for
this Biden re-election bid well first
let me say that Byron York is correct
the chickens have come home to roost
this unfair effort to prevent a dynamic
race among Democrats is harming the
support of Joe Biden it would be better
to defeat your opponents fair and square
now when you talk about third party
candidates you start to see people that
are just going to peel off this election
is probably going to be pretty tight the
polling numbers show this election is
really close every one percent of Voters
on the left that go with someone other
than Joe Biden his opportunities
look at the prediction polls where
people are betting for the first time in
this election cycle we're seeing
something that we didn't see last time
and that is at no point the prediction
betting polls show that Trump was likely
to prevail well in 2020 they're already
showing that Trump is likely to the
entrance of other third party candidates
is likely to exacerbate that phenomenon
Byron really quickly do you agree with
some who said that Trump including yours
truly by the way some have said that for
Trump to really win he's got to get to
like 55 percent given how the Democrats
managed to you know creatively you know
find votes or you know they're really
good at mail-in ballots but that this
has to be bigger than a squeaker uh to
have the real confidence that Trump can
win this listen if he manages to get
through the Minefield of his trials next
year and he wins the Republican
nomination he's still going to have an
incredibly difficult time winning a
general election there are large
percentages of Americans who say they
will not vote for Donald Trump and
there's a very interesting lesson from
the 2022
midterms which would there are a lot of
Voters who said that the economy wasn't
very good it wasn't helping them they
would normally vote against the
Democratic party but they voted for
Democrats because the Democrats had done
such a good job convincing of the threat
of Maga that would be multiplied in a
2024 Biden Trump rematch all right Byron
Horace great to see Bill y both of you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else